don't try to chase me ready to be
touched again these old guys on the wall
who lives here Calista Flockhart let's
we're already damaged after they fell
there what am I supposed to do around
here anyway sit in a share circle talk
about my feelings and how would I do
that exactly cuz where the [ __ ] is
everyone it's always just you we
megasonic teenage longest name I said no
touching you think the studio would
throw us a bone one that doesn't end up
in my mouth the first movie made more
money than the guy who invented pants
he can't just dust off one of the famous
x-men how about that putz with the giant
pigeon wings what do those do anyway huh
carry me three feet off the ground to
snatch up the nearest muffin crumb no no
no no I am NOT x-men material at all
first off I'm not even a virgin not
working out at all
masking tape it is no friend to chilled
aluminum velcro color-coded efficient
environmentally friendly who's he
talking to
why's he dressed like a registered sex
offender can we focus for a moment
ladies please we need to talk about next
month's meal plan obviously everyone
hated this ceviche I read the suggestion
box yeah it's on I'm gonna stop you
right there I see through this weak Act
you may have fooled Colossus with this
nice guy [ __ ] but not me don't be mean
back off MTW oh no no no no no let her
go let her go it's okay she has a right
to be skeptical look at me I'm an easy
target you know historically mischief
has been my mistress so I understand but
I like to think that
you guys have really rubbed off on me I
like to think that I've rubbed off
around you too lot and for the first
time in a long while I like me I accept
your apology I never apologized I was
talking to your heart see you're not
lost cause your thoughts I'm proud
you're everything I knew you can be
thank you Colossus just trying to be the
world's best x-man sorry ex person hmm
something wrong with the soap it's fine
I just filled it give it a few more
pumps there now excuse me it's dust
bunny season and I'm hunting wabbits
hi everyone is Charlie this is gonna be
my Deadpool Easter Egg surprisingly
Deadpool predicted the ending of x-men
Dark Phoenix two years before it aired
in theaters originally the movie was
supposed to come a little bit sooner but
because of the way the production in the
release dates worked out they filmed
this Deadpool scene with the x-men part
of the scene two years before x-men Dark
Phoenix hit theaters so after we talk
about those Easter eggs I'll talk about
the future of Deadpool because Kevin
Feige the people at Marvel and the
Disney CEO have already said a lot about
what's going on with the future of
Deadpool thankfully for all of you who
are worried about Deadpool it's actually
really good news we're doing a new
giveaway for spider-man far from home
imax
tickets all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a spot I'm a
nor Deadpool comment on the video and
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this but if you haven't seen it they
released an extended cut of Deadpool 2
they just call it the Deadpool - super
duper Edition with a whole bunch of
deleted scenes extended versions of
scenes that weren't in the theatrical
cut so that's basically what these are
one of them is a wholesale deleted scene
the one with the actual x-men from Dark
Phoenix in it is from the extended
version they both help you place
Deadpool - in the timeline a little bit
so basically this scene is happening
right at the end of x-men Dark Phoenix
in Deadpool as a movie just sort of
overlaps with what's going on during
Dark Phoenix but because of the way the
movies deal with each other where
Deadpool riffs on the mainstream
smen films it just makes fun of them but
the mainstream x-men films don't really
acknowledge what's going on with
Deadpool that's why you don't see any of
this Deadpool stuff happening during
x-men Dark Phoenix they were trying to
treat that as more of a serious film
whether you loved it or hated it or
whatever
obviously the writers the producers just
don't want to deal with Deadpool from a
story standpoint even though technically
it's all the shared universe over at Fox
or used to be a shared universe because
technically now they all belong back to
marvel at Disney but Deadpool is
complaining about the studio people at
Fox not allowing him to use more big
mainstream x-men characters in his movie
he turns to camera breaks the fourth
ball and implies that they've been
throwing their dogs in his face I
wouldn't want to be caught in that
meeting then the camera shifts to the
side and you get that funny moment when
you see him standing in front of an open
door to a room in which most of the main
cast of x-men Dark Phoenix from the end
of that movie are sitting with a banner
hanging up because it's the beginning of
the next school year for all the little
kids that still actually use the
x-mansion as a traditional school they
all pause to beat beasts slowly closes
the door so as to not alert Deadpool
that they've been at the x-mansion this
whole time that he's there and they've
just been ducking him around every
corner but it's just beast Professor X
Cyclops storm Nightcrawler and
Quicksilver from the main cast
Deadpool - like I said was filming
between June and October of 2017
two full years before the theatrical
release of x-men Dark Phoenix and even
though these movies are both being made
by Fox the Deadpool production team is a
totally different group of people
creatively in Vancouver than the x-men
Dark Phoenix production team which was
working out of Toronto with a completely
separate group of producers and writers
so it's not like they were cheating and
they were telling the Deadpool people at
the end of their movie Dark Phoenix was
going to be they were just helping out
the Deadpool people and Ryan Reynolds
who asked them to participate in a cameo
scene like will you help us out but they
wrote the scene for those x-men
characters they filmed it in Toronto on
a green screen separately from the
Deadpool part of the scene because
they're both in two different cities and
just sent the footage to the Deadpool
people the Dark Phoenix people were also
in the middle of principal photography
when this Deadpool stuff was being
filmed so that's why it was easy for
them to get this main cast but like I
said in my last Dark Phoenix video
between them doing this and Deadpool -
coming out in theaters they completely
reshot the third act of door
Phoenix so the whole big last part of
the film wound up changing and this part
of the x-men scene as it was happening
at the end of that movie I'll explain in
a second with a spoiler warning in case
you haven't seen Dark Phoenix yet wound
up being very different in the final
version of the movie so spoiler warning
for the end of x-men Dark Phoenix if you
haven't seen it yet because this gets to
the big part where Deadpool sort of
predicts what the team is like at the
end of that film
Deadpool accurately predicted Jean Grey
and mystique would be gone by the end of
Dark Phoenix technically Jean Grey isn't
dead she just went full cosmic Phoenix
force and just flying around the cosmos
somewhere but mystique winds up dying
during the movie and at the end
Professor X renamed the school the Jean
Grey school for gifted youngsters then
hands over leadership of the school to
the surviving x-men team members leaving
to go travel the world and play chess
everyday with Magneto
as penance for his perceived misdeeds
during the events of the film they even
cropped the banner so that you don't see
that the new banner reads the Jean Grey
school for gifted youngsters you just
see it reads school the movie itself was
actually taking place during 1992 like
you see Quicksilver wearing that Nirvana
t-shirt that t-shirt is from 1992 so
that places this scene in the events of
Deadpool 2 in 1992 if you dig a little
bit deeper there are moments within the
Deadpool films that sort of break that
continuity they try to be very ambiguous
about what the year is but it's a lot
easier for Deadpool as a character to
get away with breaking his own
continuity if he just highlights it and
turns it into a big joke like he said
during the first film lets us go talk to
the Rufus
McAvoy or Stewart these timelines okay
there are a couple Easter eggs and that
other deleted scene of them in the
kitchen that helped place it in the
timeline a little bit too Deadpool's
messing around in the fridge getting
upset about how nothing's working the
way it should be working and starts
complaining about labels and one of them
reads wheels so he's writing new labels
for the food that Professor X keeps in
the fridge meaning that this scene is
happening before the end of Dark Phoenix
because Professor X has not left the
x-mansion for good like I said because
of the nature of the Deadpool character
don't take his own timeline too
seriously though either you can try to
charge the mainstream x-men films
timeline even though they don't seem to
care about their timeline anymore the
Deadpool does but the really good news
about Deadpool going into the future of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is that
many times I think it's at least three
separate times the Disney CEO and then
separately a couple of times Kevin Feige
have talked about how much they love
what Ryan Reynolds and the Deadpool
production team have been doing with
those movies they don't intend to try
and fix something that's not broken as
in they see that they're doing great
stuff they're just gonna let them
continue to do great stuff with those
movies I know there been rumors about
them trying to cross Ryan Reynolds
Deadpool over with spider-man and other
Marvel characters in the next couple of
years but from a continuity standpoint
Kevin Feige did say that it would be a
couple years before they start
officially crossing over or rebooting
x-men characters so Ryan Reynolds is one
of the few people who is safe from being
recast and rebooted in the MCU right now
just based on what the Disney CEO has
been saying it sounds like they're
leaning more towards doing Deadpool 3
instead of doing x-force in they'll let
Deadpool reference and make fun of all
the MCU stuff and characters that he
wants maybe give him access to a couple
of MCU characters that he wants to put
in his film but outside of him breaking
the fourth wall and referencing stuff
like the Infinity Gauntlet Thanos iron
man's death spider-man
it'll still be a relatively
self-contained storyline we'll get the
official Marvel phase 4 schedule of this
summer that may or may not have Deadpool
on it but they still do plan on making
another solo Deadpool film so don't
worry about that they have no plans to
force him to go pg-13 the only time that
he would go pg-13 is when he goes into
someone else's traditional MCU film
because I don't think the Disney has any
plans to release an r-rated mainstream
comic book films still kind of
considering Deadpool Anish thing
well the holidays thought it'd be fun my
pg-13 it's a family movie also money
also Disney if I get a chance to see
spider-man far from home early next week
or the week after I'll do a non-spoilery
review so no worries about that but
leave all your video requests in the
comments below
congratulations Lord Michael R oh you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video while you wait for
everything click here to learn about
that special new teaser that Marvel
dropped for Wolverine and Avengers phase
4 and click here to learn how Chris
Evans is coming back during Marvel phase
4 as Captain America thank you so much
for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight